Dangerous people are indoctrinated in your children.
That's according to a leading conservative who is warning parents in a new video
about sending their kids to America's liberal colleges.
You're supporting ideologues who claimed that all truth is subjective,
that all sex differences are socially constructed and that Western imperialism
is the sole source of all third world problems.
The man in that video,
Dr. Jordan Peterson is with us right now.
He's a University of Toronto,
psychology professor and author of the world hit book.
It's called 12 rules for life,
an antidote to crisis,
which has spoken to so many people.
Uh,
Dr. Peterson,
we thank you very much for joining us live in that,
in that introduction you say,
uh,
I go to you is saying there are dangerous people teaching your children.
Who are you talking about?
Well,
increasingly and this is normally the case in the universities,
people are being taught by ideologues north by educators and idiot logs have a
very simple way of looking at the world.
They reduce it to a few principals like inequality,
unfairness and power.
Those would be the fundamental principles at the moment that are operating on
the radical left and they're on an ideological campaign.
And that's increasingly the case in in elementary,
junior high and high schools as well.
Mostly because the faculties of education are full of people who were radical.
So on.
This is well documented.
I mean even the chronicle of higher education came out a month ago with a,
with a blistering piece on faculties of education describing them is
academically suspect and ideologically possessed,
which I think is exactly right.
Well we've talked a lot about that on this program and,
but the,
the question is four for appearance,
who are thinking about sending their kids to college someday or already have is,
is this effort rather than these uh,
professors and whatnot being educators but being law,
where'd that come from?
Is it a concerted across the board thing or is it just happening by accident?
I don't know.
I think part of it,
part of it's still a hangover from the 1960s I would say,
and perhaps even a bit of a hangover from the cold war.
What do you mean?
You mean the people from the sixties and seventies are now and the ethos that
that that was,
that was broadcast so widely in the 1960s and there was a lot of stress in the
60s especially because of the Vietnam war and the consequences of the ongoing
called Warren.
We're still sort of suffering from the aftermath of that ideological battle,
but I also think the university's made a dreadful mistake expanding their
humanities per view to include disciplines like women's studies and these ethnic
studies disciplines,
which aren't disciplines.
They're pseudo disciplines I have passed and they have very,
very low academic standards and they're corrupting the rest of the enterprise.
And so,
and that's,
that's not a good thing.
What do you mean corrupting the rest of the enterprise?
Well,
you need to have standards in education.
And the fact that disciplines emerged that have no real methodology and no
method of proof,
no philosophical background,
no real history meant that and that they became degree granting enterprises and
that they,
that they emerge to produce political activists,
which is exactly what they advertise on their websites,
means that you've got to,
like,
you've got a fifth column of video logs operating behind the scenes and all
they,
there,
they spend almost all of their time engaged in political activism,
you know,
and,
and that's not good for the university as a whole or any stretch or biases or
for society as a whole.
Well,
Jordan,
if,
if somebody is thinking about sending their kids at college,
I've put three through good schools,
uh,
what should they know about where they send their kids?
I mean,
it's not like you have a big choice because a lot of the people in positions of
power in education are to the political left.
I mean,
that's just a fact.
You can go and you could go look up the heterodox academy on online.
That's run by Jonathan Heit,
Hu,
Hu Hu,
or he's a main player in it at that he's here in New York and he's tried to rank
order universities by their adherence to truth rather than social justice and
put University of Chicago at the top of the list,
for example.
And I think increasingly that parents and students will wise up and start,
start,
uh,
not tending may universities that are basically playing an ideological game.
What is the matter with having people from the ideological left to being your
children's instructors though?
I mean,
Jose late.
It depends on how you want all sides of the equation.
You want to know all the opinions.
Well,
yes you do.
But there's,
there's no evidence that the middle of the road or the conservative side of the
PA or the opinion spectrum is being represented in the humanities and the social
studies.
That's your worry if that,
and the fact that there's something to be said for the left,
but there's not very much to be said for the radical left.
And that distinction isn't being made and the left can clearly go too far as it
did many times in the 20th century.
And so when it gets too radical,
especially when there's no countering voices and there are very few,
then that's a bad,
that's a bad thing.
It's bad for education.
It's bad for broader society.
It's,
it's,
it's altogether bad.
Right?
Jordan,
you've been around the world talking your book up.
Uh,
you know,
people stop you on the street all the time.
Now,
what's the one thing you have learned since your book a 12 rules for life and
antidote to chaos came out.
How has the response been and how has it impacted you?
Who,
well,
there's,
I've learned two things.
I've learned that people are starving for a real conversation about
responsibility and meaning and about the relationship between those two things.
Because people need us sustaining meaning in their life.
And it's not to be found through rights and impulsive gratification.
It's to be found through the adoption of responsibility.
That's the first thing.
And the second thing is that people are a lot smarter than we think.
So if you allow them longform dialogue time,
even in public lectures,
there's a huge market for it.
There's a huge hunger for it,
podcasts and,
and the,
and the new video that's emerging online with these long form discussions is
that people are smarter than we thought and more,
and people can listen to very complex material.
So that's,
that's a really positive thing.
Right.
Well,
it's always a pleasure.
Thank you very much.
Thanks very much for the,
and it's actually going to be on PBS very shortly.
And of course the big book is called 12 rules for life.
It's a worldwide bestseller.
Dr. Jordan Peterson.
Thank you,
sir.
Thanks very much.